let's jump onto the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 is the number we're going to go to
our first caller today from the 91 for
area code caller tell us who you are and
jump right in here
hey David is pleasure to all with you
again my name is Dylan Rogers from
Bucknell University Greg I'm calling in
regarding something a little bit
different than last week this week I'm
calling in regarding are we seeing the
death of the political moderate in the
culture war as some like to call it the
reason I bring up this question is
because I've noticed that on a lot of
right-wing news outlets I tend to watch
on both sides of the spectrum we're
seeing more and more I guess
over-the-top content that seems to be
sensationalizing left an example include
what's wrong with the left what is fake
news the transgender fad women try
manspreading
and it seems a little bit ridiculous as
if they're trying to cater to a more
extreme audience and I've seen it on
some other for left-wing media outlets
as well so as someone who's left-leaning
but lies somewhere more in the middle I
wanted to see what your opinion on this
one well there's two things going on
right number one is that from a media
perspective there's very little
advantage to being a moderate because if
you are setting up a discussion about
whatever issue assuming you are going to
have divergent views it's way more
compelling from a ratings perspective to
have wildly divergent views versus a
moderate and a right-winger it's just
you're just going to have a left winger
and a right winger and the more
divergent those views are from a media
corporate media ratings perspective
that's going to be more interesting but
also from a legislative perspective
there's not that much of a benefit to
being a moderate and and the moderate
views are being crowded out and
Obamacare is sort of a perfect example
because President Obama went in with I'd
sort of like to have a public option
maybe you know if it's okay with you
guys the right-wingers dealing with
outrageous right-wing position and we
ended up with Obamacare which is pretty
damn right-wing there's no advantage to
that President Obama as I said before
should have come in with Medicare for
all is my position let's now negotiate
from that
now it could have led to Obamacare never
being done but the bigger picture is
there's very little advantage if we
think about this as a sort of prisoner's
dilemma game theory situation there's
very little advantage to coming in with
a moderate perspective both
legislatively and on media so yeah your
observations 100 percent right Dylan
thank you so much for having me on all
right I guess what concerns me a little
bit more though it's the dangers of this
yeah well the dangers are undeniable I
mean the dangers are that you have
increasingly polarized goal posts in
terms of what counts as a position on
any particular issue and you have a
whole generation of people at this point
who have only been paying attention to
politics in the era of cable news who
might not even understand that there are
on some issues not all but on some
issues moderate solutions so it's a
problem Dylan thank you appreciate the
call we're going to move on always great
to hear from you